تصاعد التوتر بين ايران واسرائيل خلال
الاسابيع الاخيره اعاد المخاوف من تحركات
وهجمات متبادله قد تؤدي لاندلاع حرب
اقليميه
تقارير استخباراتيه اشارت الى سعي طهران
لتزويد الميليشيات التابعه لها بمعدات
عسكريه هذا تاهبا لاي ضربه عسكريه في
المستقبل فيما بدات اوروبا تتخذ موقف اكثر
تشددا تجاه طهران بعد تزويدها لموسكو
بمنظومات عسكريه استخدمتها الاخيره في
حربها ضد اوكرانيا حول هذا الموضوع معنا
في الاستوديو الاستاذه رياض قهوجي
المستشار العسكري لبرنامج عسكري رياض اهلا
بك معنا في هذه الفقره لماذا يعود الان
التصعيد ما بين اسرائيل وايران وكذلك ما
هي الرسائل التي حملتها الضربات الاخيره
التي يقال ان اسرائيل نفذتها في العمق
الايراني يعني اولا الجديد اليوم هو عوده
حكومه نتنياهو للسلطه
شاهدنا خلال فتره حكم نتنياهو السابقه
تصعيد في العمل داخل اراضي ايرانيه عمليه
اغتيال العلماء الايرانيين قصف
حاولت تفجير مهاجمه منشات نوويه ومنشات
تصنيع صواريخ هذه الامور توقفت مع حكومات
بنت
وحكومات وبسط يسار اليوم عوده حكومه
اليمين ان نشهد هذا التطور الامر الاخر هو
الساعه المتعلقه بالتحصيب هناك تقدم كبير
في عمليه التخصيب اليورانيوم من جانب
ايران في وقت لا كاميرات مراقبه
تتبع ما يجري داخل المنشات التحصيب النووي
الايراني وبالتالي هناك مستوى القلق باتك
كبير جدا في اسرائيل ودول الاوروبيه في
موضوع هذا هذا الملف النووي الايراني
وهناك لكن هذه المره ما تم استهدافه استاذ
رياض يقال حينا بانه مصنع لطائرات مسيره
وفي حين احيان اخرى يقال بانه مصنع
للصواريخ الهلسيه كذلك هو مصنع
للصواريخ البلاي ومنظومات التوجيه علينا
اتذكر هناك علاقه مباشره بين برنامج ناو
الايراني وبين البرنامج الصواريخ الصواريخ
البلاستيكيه هي اداه توصيل الرؤوس النوويه
مستقبلا لايران وبالتالي الخطوه التاليه
لبرنامج النووي الايراني هو تصنيع راس
حربي يوضع على صواريخ بالستيو وبالتالي
تكنولوجيا الصواريخ البلاستيه مرتبطه بشكل
كبير بتكنولوجيا التطوير النووي استاذ
رياض تقارير استخباراتيه مؤخرا اشارت بانه
ايران بتسرع من وتيره تزويد الميليشيات
التابعه لها في المنطقه بمعدات عسكريه
حديثه لماذا يعني لماذا هذه العمليه تسريع
هذه العمليه ايران على مدى سنوات تمد هذه
الميليشيات لكن لماذا الان تسريع هذه
الوتيره وهل تنوي ايران اشعال حرب اقليميه
في المنطقه اذا تم استهدافها في الداخل
ايران تدرك ان هناك قرار اسرائيل امريكي
اوروبي بمنعها امتلاك سلاح نووي وبالتالي
كلما تقدم برنامجها النووي سيكون هناك عمل
عسكري لايقافها لان المفاوضات جناب انتهت
لعوده لها حسب جميع التوقعات وبالتالي
هناك مسار تصاعدي وتصعيد اليوم في المجال
العسكري وبالتالي ايران تحاول ان
تعزز قدرات قواتها الاماميه هذه
الميليشيات في سوريا في لبنان في العراق
هي قوات اماميه للجيش الايراني او للحرس
الثور الايراني ستكون هي خط خط الهجوم
الاول استاذ رياض تزويد ايران روسيا
بمسيارات وكذلك بصواريخ تم استخدامها في
الحرب ضد اوكرانيا يعني احدث تحول في
الموقف الاوروبي وبات اكثر تشددا تجاه
طهران لكن الى اي مدى الدول التي تشكل لها
ايران الان خطر وتشكل عليها ايران خطر
سواء هنا في منطقه الشرق الاوسط او على
مستوى العالم من الممكن ان تستفيد عسكريه
من هذا الموقف الاوروبي ويعني تحدث
استراتيجيه موحده حول العالم لمجابهه
النظام الايراني اعتقد ان ايران ارتكبت
خطا استراتيجي بدخولها الحرب في اوروبا اي
عمل عسكري قد تقام اليوم قد تقوم به
اسرائيل ضد ايران لن نشاهد هذه الممانعه
كما قد كانت ستكون سابقا من جانب دول
اوروبيه ومن هنا هذا الخطا الاستراتيجي
ايران ادخلت نفسها وازماتها الازمات التي
لها يد في المنطقه فيما يجري في اوروبا
اليوم استاذ رياض الشرط بانه الحرب في
اوكرانيا ادت الى تنامي وتطور العلاقات
العسكريه ما بين موسكو وطهران والان طهران
يعني تسعى للحصول على الكثير من الاسلحه
الروسيه لكن برايك ما هي المنظومات التي
تحرص ولدا طهران حرص في الحصول عليها من
الجانب الروسي هناك قلق من ثلاثه امور
اولا تكنولوجيا الاسلحه الفرد صوتيه التي
ستجعل الصواريخ البلاستيه الايرانيه اكثر
فتكا وقدره على اختراق الدفاعات في
اسرائيل وفي دول اخرى في المنطقه ثاني شيء
هو
منظومات الاس 400 للدفاع الجوي والتي
ستجعل اي عمل عسكري عبر غارات جويه من
جانب اسرائيل او حتى امريكا تواجه خطر
اكبر من الدفاعات الايرانيه وطبعا البعد
الثالث هو برايي ليس بذلك الاهميه مثلا
مثل تعزيز قدرات ق واتها الجويه مثل اس يو
35 اشكرك شكرا جزيلا استاذ رياض قهوجي
المستشار العسكري لبرنامج عسكريا شكرا على
هذه شكرا